thank you you know I just came back from
lunch I went Japanese restaurant where
there's this Korean waiter tonight
you know when I first started I did a
selfie sort of thing and then talked to
her and I said a few words of Korean
that I could say then so now I've been
at it for 68 days I went back there in
so far as you know just small talk
chitchat I was no better than I was that
well I mean because it's so difficult
cheap
first of all any language you don't
speak well if there's lots of background
noise I don't hear the words if I knew
that language well you almost anticipate
you know what she's gonna say there's a
limited range of things she's gonna say
you've heard them all before you know
exactly what she's saying even if you
only pick up to the 25 words but I'm
relying on hearing every word I can hear
every word plus I'm not very good I
haven't done you know yeah but I've
spent I don't know how many hours you
know 60 days times probably an average
of 2 or 3 hours a day so my vocabulary I
can understand the this very difficult
podcast on literature almost the same
for me in English for example when I
know what what the topic is and like I
kind of expect what you'll be told right
so I can easily catch the words and
understand the general idea would but
when it's kind of background noise and
some unexpected topics it's also very
challenging to know because because you
have to to be concentrated more than in
your native language when you just can
pick some words and from the context to
understand I often get people are
commenting here I'm a YouTube channel
they're saying you know I can read and I
can understand but but I can't
understand movies for the same reason we
don't know the context that well there's
lots of
yes so so I think the important thing is
to you know not be discouraged I'm not
discouraged
I mean if I were to spend two hours a
day making small talk with the waitress
you know okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna pay you you sit
there and you you know ask me if I need
anything more and what I want to order
and I spent my whole time doing that I'd
get very good at small talk but that's
not so important to me I'm more
motivated again to understand more and
more of this interesting podcast
listening today and in the long run I'm
more motivated to one day be able to
have an intelligent conversation with a
Korean person on a wide variety of
studies and I think when I have that
level the small talk will kind of come
along it's difficult I remember when I
visited with mark when he was playing
professional hockey in Japan and after
his game we went out with his buddies
Japanese hockey players and mark was
very good at all the casual slam Egypt
is awful I wasn't very good at mm-hmm
all I ever did was talk to business
people all right so yeah so you can
easily talk about business and all this
stuff but right when it comes to talking
about weather or movies maybe fashion so
we can never cover it all and so every
time that someone again on my youtube
channel said that they have to write
some exam and wow they're confident
about their ability it seems there are
all these words that come up that they
don't know yeah there are always going
to be I'm sure as good as your English
please I'm sure that there are words
that come up whether when you're reading
or in conversation that you haven't
earned the fun yeah sure so yeah it is
the case for jokes also jokes are
difficult to understand and do you go to
say something funny so that people
understand you and love jokes cuz
there's always a few key words right
those are the words you don't know right
yeah yeah I get the thing in Russian you
know I like
I really want to get this joke now but
it's always gonna be one or two keys
mine here whatever words and so at that
point the joke is gone okay everybody's
laughing I'm not laughing anyway so I
think the important thing is just to not
get discouraged there's a lot of there's
a lot of little it's not that easy yeah
it takes time it just takes time effort
okay thank you thank you